Liberals are losing their minds after
getting schooled by Ron DeSantis the
College Board removing controversial
woke lessons from an AP African-American
studies curriculum after the Florida
governor rejected them but Progressive
politicians and media figures are
outraged the College Board claims they
didn't take into account any political
leaders considerations but good orgasm
Gavin Newsom isn't buying that tweeting
I call BS you are merely a puppet of
Rhonda santis and others are lobbying
personal attacks against DeSantis
unfortunately you know Governor Sanchez
has been very very clear he has what
just appears to be a white nationalist
agenda it's never been about this course
the governor was very clear
African-American studies doesn't have
educational value he's basically
sacrificing the education of a whole
generation of people he's trying for for
his ambition it's a right-wing Fantasy
Land like Disney World but in hell
to Florida the meanest place on Earth
okay all right I'll start with you Greg
that's a great slogan I would move to
the meanest place on Earth perfect for
you please get done at the meanest place
on Earth I don't like nice places all
right is this a white nationalist agenda
that's taking out black queer studies
BLM and reparations no because they're
very specific about what they're looking
at they're looking at stuff like uh
queer Theory and this kind of radical
Marxism stuff that that tends to kind of
seep into everything because it's coming
out of the campuses and it's now in our
high schools I never thought it would
but it's happening but the big story
here I think is about education itself
it's no longer a given that left-wing
agent prop can freely flow into your
into your classroom or into your
curriculum parents are truly woke right
they're woke to the woke uh they're not
gonna roll over anymore so if you want
queer theory for kids you're gonna have
to fight for it and that's what this is
really about it's not about any kind of
censorship or Banning it's about you
know what we're now reading the
brainwash that you've been shooting into
our into these books and we don't like
it you have to defend it we don't have
to defend we don't have to defend
protecting our kids you have to tell us
why a six-year-old needs to know about
gender affirmation surgery I want to
hear you I want to hear that explanation
and they can and I think you know I
think you I just saw a statistic the
other day that the the number one group
for homeschooling and growth is are
black families interesting that is a
great sign because education
education has got to change because once
there's a competitive element to it
through school choice it's over you know
Dana Randy Weingarten said that uh she
assured us that critical race Theory
wasn't being taught in the schools and
uh she calls Governor DeSantis a race
Bader
yeah that was actually that was my first
point that I was going to make is that
for years I said CRT is not even
happening right but now they're upset
because it's not happening is that what
you're upset about and this as for
governor Newsom he didn't say he didn't
even write it's BS he wrote the full
word no yes he did what did you do when
you saw it Dana I was outpaced did you
wash your eyes out
no I did that's why my eyes
you feel like he looks like he's
flailing if you have to write that in a
tweet that's not leadership you look
pretty pitiful and it'll be funny to see
if he tries to go to South Carolina to
actually compete in a Democratic primary
either in 24 or 28 because I just don't
think that most people are going to want
to go for that kind of leadership and
it's not just because of the cursing
it's because of this like being unhinged
um also the last thing I would say is
it's a seven this is a 70 30 issue and
they don't realize it which is what you
were just saying is that you have more
and more people choosing to try
something different with their education
you have full State saying actually you
know what we're going to allow the
dollars allotted to each student to
follow them wherever they want to go for
Education that's a trend that starts in
a few States and then it starts to grow
so Republicans have a way here to try to
make education something that is an
issue that they can show parents they
really care about no matter what your
the rest of your ideology the kids
matter and in 2024 that election is
going to be about that them I think you
know Jesse notice how they Infuse
transgenderism with race so that if
you're if you know if you're against it
you're not only a racist you're a
homophobic I mean they they make it so
that whatever way you disagree you're a
horrible person yeah sometimes it's time
saving for justice
get it all in there at once
it's called me a bad guy this country
needs more honesty people have to give
Ron DeSantis the benefit of the doubt
like I give Joe Biden the benefit of the
doubt because until when
Jesse Waters this story and he says to
himself this is a governor who is now
established
AP African-American history courses for
the first time in the State of Florida
that is a really good accomplishment but
the view sees this as a klansman Banning
slavery being taught in schools it's
insane
if the College Board admits and they did
that the socialism the empty the prisons
the intersectionality whatever that
means is too much for high school kids
it's too much for high school kids do
you remember what you were like in high
school judge could you have handled
queer Theory as a junior no I went to
Catholic High School exactly never
mention it exactly the people that are
complaining about this should actually
maybe take AP African-American studies
they might learn something and they cut
the fat out and now it's lean and it's
mean and it's just history and that's a
good thing and just history slavery
reconstruction civil rights that's in
there the problem is
a politician is interfering with the
substance of what's being taught in the
school it's fine when you like the guy
or now destantis you know he's he's on a
roll everybody's watching with
admiration and uh wondering how far he's
going to go and all the rest what
happens if he's the guy that you really
thinks thinks what happens if he's
opposite your point of view and here he
is and he is attacking curriculum the
the province of parents and Educators
now he's inserting this political
activism in the midst of it so you say
Gavin newsom's a dope uh what if Gavin
Newsom was doing this how would we feel
if Gavin Newsom was the one saying that
the AP course and uh something else on
the books that the legislator passed
that you can't pull woke stuff off in
school
what law is that what do you mean what
law they passed it it's the anti-wolk
law
you mean in Florida this goes against
their laws in Florida but Iran DeSantis
is making a political play he wants to
be president of the United States he
understands what Greg was talking about
how this will impact uh the the
Democrats as they try to defend
transgenderism and all the rest of it he
they all know what they're doing I'm I
know what they're doing too no now it's
okay it's got to be you know
if Rhonda Santa's criticized Gavin
Newsom it's just the opposite that's the
only political play here I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now